hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 15 video just
careful for spoilers if you have not
seen it yet never before was crying
Daryl a more appropriate reaction shot
there is a new round of the giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video because the finale is next week
I'll explain at the end of this what's
going on with bonus videos and all the
good stuff that's gonna happen before
season 7 so let's have she do top 5 WTF
and then there'll be a couple of comic
book Easter eggs
most of the comic book stuff is negan
related I've already done a negan
trailer video so I'll put a link to that
in the description but there were some
comic book things in this episode too if
you do want to read along in the comics
start with vol 17 that picks up right
where the Dwight stuff picked up last
week so number five WTF Carol leaves
they actually rewind it in time because
we got the note last week now we
actually saw what happened before that
they play the Johnny Cash song and then
they jump to Glenn and Maggie in the
shower and a couple other groups on the
show like Rick and Michonne we have to
talk about them in a second - but Carol
leaving - arrow goes after her then a
bunch of people chased after him
fracturing the safes up making them very
weak right or wrong I feel like Carol is
gonna get vilified for this everything
bad that his coming is totally gonna
flow from the comic books so technically
you can't blame Carol the TV show had to
find a way to create the circumstances
that lead to the events of issue 100 in
the comics Harold just drew the short
straw they just decided to push her
character in a direction they would
cause her to think that leaving is the
only option because I can't kill for any
of the people that I love number 4 WTF
does not take her long to break that
rule doesn't have to go down this way I
did love the way they played that where
we as the audience has way more
information and you could definitely
type I feel like anybody watching this
would know what this scene is leading to
that she's just begging them that it
doesn't have to go this way because
she's getting ready to kill them they
just don't know it
number three WTF seeing that Carol has
made a terrible decision Daryl does not
want to be left behind on the bad
decisions trained in decides that he
can't go back to the safe so until he
resolves the conflict with Dwight more
of an internal conflict like he's trying
to atone for what he did not do for not
killing Dwight when he had the chance
Rosita you could argue
was either trying to join Daryl to atone
for what happened to Denise or what
happened with Abraham either way all
kinds of people making all kinds of
terrible decisions in this episode so
naturally it's just going from bad to
worse when number two WTF
Dwight gets the drop on Clin and
Michonne and then number one WTF gets
the drop on Daryl and shoots him
seemingly killing him so there are
really two emotions when that happened
that I feel like most people had one
you're either like oh my god did they
just kill Daryl or two the other being
confusion like oh my god like they can't
kill Daryl so what the hell just
happened here how they can explain this
so as Dwight says you're gonna be fine
so it seems like he probably just shot
it through the shoulder or did something
to mortally wound him if they don't
treat him but he has at least as much
time as they have through the end of the
finale to to be healed but now just
taking stock Carol is still on the loose
she's out there somewhere Morgan is out
looking for her Rick came back everyone
else was captured by its white so Dwight
and the Savior's now have a clen
Michonne Daryl and Rosita captive so we
just got to say it I definitely think
Daryl is gonna be fine I think what
they're doing with this end WTF
cliffhanger is a better version of what
they tried to do with Glenn where it's
like oh my god is he dead
is he alive so Dwight shooting Daryl is
just a better version of the dumpster
but I don't think that there's anybody
on the show that is completely
unkillable I do feel like daryl is one
of those people that's destined to make
it to the end one of those tragic
figures who will just have to watch all
of his friends die it's much harder to
watch a person who doesn't make friends
easily make friends and then watch them
all die one at a time that just feels
like the type of sadness that the
Walking Dead puts on you week to week
here's my big question for you guys
because they've created a situation now
where they could totally do what happens
during issue 100 of the comics just
trying not to be super exploited or
anything like that do you think it will
go down the same way it does in the
comics with negan and Lucille just in
the interest of not being crazy spoilery
just use a spoiler tag in spacebar like
four or five times down if you want to
talk about specifics or you can just say
no I don't think it's going to be like
it is in the comics or you can just
say yeah I think they'll do it exactly
like it happens in the comics more to
that comic book Easter eggs Maggie
cut her hair short in the comics this is
what she looks like in the comics and
second big Easter egg look at the gun
that Carl took the etching on it is a
baseball bat wrapped in barbed wire just
like negan's bat Lucille so I feel like
even if they don't go that route the
producers want you to think that they're
gonna do exactly what happens in the
comics and I'm talking about issue 100
specifically if you didn't see my negan
trailer video next week's episode is
introducing negan issue 100 of the comic
book is the issue that introduced the
negan character so like I said if you
want to read up with the comics just
start with volume 17 and you'll have a
pretty good idea of what might end up
happening in the finale next week
I think volume 18 is gonna be what they
do for the majority of season 7 in terms
of storyline but as bad as things can
get for the survivors I feel like
Morgan's comment anybody can come back
is a really good benchmark anybody can
come back from anything so as bad as
things will get in the finale and during
season 7 they can still always come back
so please just be careful when you're
posting about spoilery stuff in the
comments in related news there's been a
whole bunch of Batman V Superman stuff
happening I just posted a video
explaining what Zack Snyder has said
about the ending and what's going on in
Justice League so there are a few other
things that I need to catch up on like
Game of Thrones and some videos that I
had to skip this week so I'll try and
get those out as fast as possible
giveaway time congratulations to last
week's giveaway winner Cain you and a
$20 Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page after I post my
Walking Dead finale video next week what
I'll do is I'll do like a season 7
predictions video I think there will be
some very specific things from the
comics so they'll be planning a comic
book stuff to talk about
after negan shows up cannot wait I'm so
excited for him why you guys wait for me
to post my next video you can click here
for that negan trailer video I do an
explainer for negan in the comics and
you can click here for my Batman V
Superman Justice League explainer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight